matter where you look spider in is there
it was it was incredible the great thing
about spider-man is that we all identify
with we all relate to him he's us so the
idea that you get to feel what he feels
I can fly the way he flies is a whole
other way to to zero in on the character
it's really cool it's really fun I saw
all the other spider-man although the
movies and I just want to see the
president start fresh new faces I've
been a spider-man fan for forever you
know I think every kid my age probably
was I'm very excited I can't wait to see
Andrew Garfield and see how he's gonna
fill into the new spider-man character I
think everybody's really anticipating
that [ __ ] movie like this it's you know
you're there's always so much because
I've been about it they're definitely
gonna have shots of him flying around
I'd like to see spider-man's POV and I
imagine it was just good oh my god
the immersive component of IMAX's is
very special when you combine it with
this kind of action especially with this
movie it's like imax and 3d and
spider-man we're all made for each other
it's also my story and I'm exile of I my
special hubble 3d and imax well I was
like that shouldn't be legal to have
that much fun in a movie theater that
was the most unreal to see if there's
parts of the film where we actually
expanded the aspect ratio so we opened
the screen up so you can get a very
specific IMAX experience that becomes
even more immersive than we've seen
before that whole fight sequence at the
end was stunning
the guys flying through the city streets
with skyscrapers and webs how could that
not be an amazing experience in imax 3d
you are in flight you're sitting on
spider-man shoulder shoulder I love I
magnetin always makes it better every
film should be seen an imax it's amazing
i mean it's Oprah is so clear it makes
the experience so you I want to marry
imax is that possible